Boa noite minhas amigas meus amigos para
mais uma live temos aqui uma pessoa
muito especial uma doutora excelente
aqui de Balneário Camburiu que é uma
especialista em medicina
fitocanabinoides
esse assunto fascinante dos
fitocanabinoides fitocanabinoides com
profundidade é a Dra Caroline Fontes que
é formada 15 anos dedica à integrativa
já há vários anos fez a formação Dr
Ribeiro como eu fiz né e ela possui
pós--graduação em medicina automo
medicina funcional tem mestrado em
terapia neural pela Universidade de
Barcelona e é palestrante professora de
pós--graduação em
ortomolecular sobre especificamente
canabis cannabis medicinal e Terapia
neural Boa noite D Caroline falei certo
aí As
suas tributo sim boa noite tudo bem
Inclusive a gente fez Lair juntos né Foi
na mesma época né a tur era grande Ach a
gente não interagiu muito na época da da
pós Porque a turma era meio grande mas
acho que foi na mesma época que nós
fizemos sim foi foi no mesmo ano mesmo
ano
então pode falar querida não é isso
mesmo a introdução e eu na verdade fui
intensiv por quase 10 Anos Antes de ir
pra medicina integrativa e depois que a
gente conheceu né passamos pelo Lair
realmente mudou tudo e agora só na
medicina integrativa e no cannabis
medicinal eu prescrevo há uns se anos
foi quando eu comecei a estudar sobre o
assunto até por uma questão eh de
familiar próximo assim a primeira pessoa
para quem eu prescrevi o motivo de eu
ter começado a estudar foi por uma uma
prima minha com questão estão de
depressão de uso de vários medicamentos
tentativas de suicídio e quando eu fiz o
primeiro curso e comecei a usar nela e
vi realmente os efeitos foi quando eu
fui aprofundar mais o estudo sobre o
assunto que é apaixonante né que tem
muita coisa aí pra gente
ver maravilha então vamos começar
perguntando Quais são as condições
médicas mais comuns na sua opinião que
podem se beneficiar do uso dos
fitocanabinoides
Então são inúmeras Na verdade até o
primeiro curso de cannabis que eu fiz
acho que em 2017 ou 18 eh ainda tinha-se
muita coisa para descobrir sobre os
fitocanabinoides mas lá falava-se muito
sobre as inúmeras indicações desde
doenças a imones ansiedade depressão
insônia doenças
psiquiátricas autismo neurodegenerativas
Alzheimer Parkinson e eu saí do curso
pensando meu deus serve para tudo né né
como que uma única planta um único ativo
vai servir para tantas doenças e quando
a gente entende realmente o
funcionamento do sistema
endocanabinoide a gente consegue
compreender um pouco melhor o porqu de
tantas indicações mas são todas essas e
muitas outras que eu fui descobrindo ao
longo da prática né às vezes paciente me
procurava Ah eu tenho doença de hant
então eu tenho né doenças às vezes que a
gente pouco via e que procurando
buscando estudos tem realmente inúmeras
indicações por conta desse equilíbrio do
sistema endocanabinoide que eu acho que
vale a pena a gente explicar um
pouquinho eh de forma leiga até como eu
explico pros pacientes que nós temos
isso foi descoberto no ano de 2000 então
é muito recente né Inclusive a gente não
estudou isso na grade curricular
acadêmica né não tinha isso na faculdade
era algo que não se sabia mas nós temos
um sistema endocanabinoide o corpo
humano tem esse sistema que foi
elucidado no ano de 2000 Então a gente
tem eh receptores canabinoides
distribuídos em todo o corpo desde
cérebro todos os órgãos periféricos e
eles viram que como eu tenho receptores
eu produzo no meu corpo uma coisa
chamada endocanabinoides que são
canabinoide que a gente produz para se
ligar nesses receptores e o equilíbrio
desses Sista é responsável por todas as
nossas funções fisiológicas desde sono
né a parte de energia função
mitocondrial então consequentemente o
desequilíbrio desse sistema também gera
inúmeros sintomas e doenças né Então
como que o o óleo de cannabis entraria
nisso e ele a gente extrai através da
planta da cannabis os fitocanabinoides
igual eu extraio faço óleos essen iis eu
extraio fitocanabinoides da planta e
esses fitocanabinoides se ligam nesses
receptores que eu tenho com mecanismos
de ação diferentes de acordo com o
efeito que eu tô buscando desde um
efeito antiinflamatório um efeito né
analgésico eh então a gente fala muito
na época falava-se somente do cbd e do
thc que é o que muita gente conhece né O
cbd que tem mais um potencial
antiinflamatório o thc mais um potencial
de
neuromodulação né de atuar nos nossos
receptores cerebrais para regularem
liberação de
neurotransmissores então por isso a
gente entendendo esse sistema a gente
entende porque tamanha aplicabilidade em
diferentes
comorbidades sim é muito impressionante
a quantidade de aplicações né Itec para
pessoas assim mais desconfiadas né chega
a parecer que é uma panaceia e panaceia
sempre tem uma conotação negativa em
medicina mas nós que fizemos medicina
integrativa funcional sabemos que não é
bem assim que tem substâncias realmente
que tem eh centenas de aplicações
terapêuticas só saber utilizar da melhor
forma possível né assim como você
estudou muito o assunto e sabe fazer aí
com maestria né então como é que a
medicina canabinoides na sua opinião Se
integra aos tratamentos tradicionais
quando é que você escolhe por exemplo
usar
um medicamento tradicional ou um
medicamento ortomolecular ou um
fitoterápico ou quando você escolhe
associar ou não um fitocanabinoides
os medicamentos são sim necessários uma
coisa que vale a pena a gente falar é
que o equilíbrio do organismo como um
todo faz toda a diferença no equilíbrio
do sistema endocanabinoide né Como Eu
mencionei a gente produz
endocanabinoides de forma natural Mas
quem produz esses endocanabinoides eh
eles são produzidos no nosso corpo
através de ácidos graxos que vem
principalmente do citosol das células
hepáticas né do fígado então muitas
vezes a gente pega pacientes Isso é o
que a gente vê todos os dias com
alterações hepáticas com alimentação
inflamatória né seja intoxicação por
metais pesados ou que ingerem muita
bebida alcoólica então várias questões
que desregulam o sistema do corpo vão
diminuir a produção desses
endocanabinoides né então no início
falava-se muito sobre o uso do Óleo de
cannabis como última opção terapêutica
quando nada mais surtia efeito e hoje
não é o que a gente faz na prática né
então a gente utiliza eu prescrevo o
óleo muitas vezes como primeira opção
terapêutica se eu pego um paciente com
um quadro de ansiedade de crise de
pânico em depressão que muitas vezes
ainda não usa nenhum medicamento eu
posso sim introduzir o óleo como uma
primeira opção em vez de introduzir um
medicamento controlado que com certeza
vai ter muito mais efeitos colaterais
repercussões e riscos de dependência
né eu Concordo totalmente contigo
Inclusive eu tenho utilizado Lógico eu
não tenho a mesma experiência que você e
com os fitocanabinoides mas eu tenho
utilizado bastante Para justamente eh
como alternativa a várias medicações aí
fármacos são utilizados com muita
frequência aí como ação ansiolítica ou
para induzir o sono Inclusive a gente
tem pacientes você estava comentando
comigo antes de gente entrar ao vivo que
a gente consegue tirar ele de
medicamentos muito problemáticos que
inclusive induzem a a demência o déf
cognitivo com os fitocanabinoides
e é bem interessante isso eu acho que é
uma alternativa muito
válida não sei se você acompanhou alguns
estudos mostrando que praticamente todos
os indutores do Sono T aumento de risco
de déf cognitivo e demência
eh não só não só realmente os
ansiolíticos convencionais né os bos
diazepínico mas também os outros de
geração nova também que não são B
diazepínico
aumenta o risco aí de várias condições
então pacientes por exemplo que TM
doenças neurodegenerativas e são
agitados à noite que é muito comum eh é
bem comum o psiquiatra ou neurologista
passarem né Eh agentes antipsicóticos né
para induzir o sono e eu acho que nesse
caso os fitocanabinoides são bem mais
interessantes você tem experiência aí de
uso nessa circunstâncias aí paxon
Alzheimer outras doenças
neurodegenerativas
bastante eh Inclusive essa questão que a
gente pode utilizar como primeira forma
terapêutica e também como Associação aos
medicamentos com o intuito de desmamar
muitos medicamentos né eu tenho vários
pacientes que usam para Parkinson e que
eu fui aos poucos reduzindo a dose da
levodopa que já tava muitas vezes em
doses elevadas então a gente observa
bastante isso no Alzheimer então que a
gente não tem um medicamento que né que
trate doença é uma questão muito
sintomática nada posterga ela impede a
evolução da doença e o óleo realmente
traz muito mais eh ele atua em toda a
fisiopatologia da doença
neurodegenerativa né no Parkinson por
exemplo como ele faz uma neuromodulação
Ele regula a liberação de dopamina Então
melhora muito e eu vejo e a necessidade
de redução dos medicamentos do Parkinson
do Alzheimer com a introdução do óo
perfeito perfeito muito bom e a gente eh
só para reforçar quando a gente pega por
exemplo que eu falei que eu comecei a
prescrever o óleo por conta de uma prima
próxima que usava cinco
antidepressivos e com a introdução do
óleo em menos de se meses a gente
retirou todos os medicamentos e hoje até
hoje Ela utiliza né somente o óleo então
ele possibilita realmente o desmame de
vários medicamentos e tem até alguns
vídeos no aqui no YouTube mesmo
mostrando pro Parkinson uma evolução
muito rápida de pacientes com crises de
tremor e o uso do Óleo chega a ser
impressionante assim de melhora do
sintomas em questão de 15 minutos se a
gente digita ali Parkinson e e uso de
cannabis é uma evolução que realmente a
gente vê na prática assim a melhora do
tremor é muito
rápida e no paxon seria realmente
aquela preparação que tem meio a meioo
canab canabinol com canab perdão
canabidiol com
thc Então essa questão eh muitos estudos
em várias comorbidades a gente usaria um
teor maior de thc do que de cbd só que
no Brasil a nossa autorização paraa
importação de thc é a de até
0.3% então a gente não tem de óleos
importados eh óleo de um para um um de
cbd para um de thc que eu acho que vale
a pena a gente explicar um pouco isso
porque assim o cbd ele é o composto eh
não psicoativo da planta o thc já é o
ativo psicoativo porque isso muitos
pacientes têm dúvidas e tinham muito
medo de usar um óleo com thc pensando na
questão da psicoatividade que isso não
tem nada a ver com o uso Recreativo da
planta Por exemplo quando a pessoa usa
um cannabis uma cannabis de forma
recreativa fumada é uma cannabis com um
teor alto de thc que tem esse potencial
de psicoatividade o óleo hoje no Brasil
importado tem até 0.3% de thc então ele
não tem potencial de psicoatividade ao
mesmo tempo eu preciso desse thc a nível
principalmente de sistema nervoso
central para regular essa liberação de
neurotransmissores então na maior parte
das comorbidades que a gente usa o óleo
é necessário ter essa pequena quantidade
de
thc perfeito bem eh a próxima pergunta
que eu quero fazer a você é se existem
efeitos colaterais significativos se
você vê alguns efeitos problemáticos
associados ao uso de cannabis ou de
canabinoides
sim existem vários efeitos alguns
efeitos colaterais que são são relatados
eh principalmente com o uso do thc em
dose elevada porque fora do Brasil por
exemplo eh o óleo veio muito muita parte
dos estudos vieram de Israel né o médico
a pessoa que descobriu o sistema
endocanabinoide que foi Rafael Mulan ele
é de Israel lá temse óleos por exemplo
com proporção de 80% de thc para 20 de
cbd mas Lembrando que muitas vezes o que
seria um efeito colateral para uma
pessoa pode ser o que a gente espera de
efeito e benefício para outra né o thc
tem um potencial maior analgésico ele
pode aumentar o apetite então pro
paciente com Alzheimer por exemplo que
tem de redução de apetite ou paciente
com tratamento de câncer paliativo com
dor crônica o thc é muito
importante mas quando a gente regula eh
o organismo do paciente quando eu regulo
esse sistema melhoro a função intestinal
hepática o que a gente vê na prática que
a gente utiliza doses muito menores do
que os próprios estudos mostram pelo
sistema endocanabinoide do paciente
estar mais regulado mas de efeitos
colaterais poderia ser até a
psicoatividade por uma um efeito alto né
Por uma dose alta do thc ter essa
alteração de psicoatividade
eh alterar a
questão do paciente acordar mais cansado
de ter náusea mas na prática
efetivamente eu vejo isso muito pouco ou
quase nada porque eu começo doses muito
baixas começo primeiro desintoxicando
desinflamando melhorando a função do
fígado né a função hepática e começo
doses muito baixas e vou acompanhando
esse paciente semanalmente no início
aumentando a dose gradativamente de
acordo com a tolerância dele com a
melhora dos sintomas Porque para mim A
ideia é a gente atingir a menor dose pro
melhor efeito então requer realmente um
acompanhamento próximo ali no início e
fazendo isso dificilmente eu tenho algum
efeito colateral né porque eu já não
introduzo doses elevadas que poderiam
causar
isso sim sim essa é a minha percepção
também a gente fazendo o trabalho todo
de base e você comentou comigo inclusive
num curso que a gente se encontrou isso
que me chamou bastante atenção essa
questão realmente preparar a base do
paciente desinflamar para que a gente
possa usar as menores doses possíveis
então na prática também eu não observo
grandes efeitos colaterais isso que me
anima muito é até a utilizar mais esses
produtos aí então
e então como é que você aborda né Eu
acho que as pessoas em comum que não
conhecem não tem uma experiência no dia
a dia então como é que você abordaria as
preocupações que os pacientes têm as
famílias têm sobre o potencial de
dependência
substâncias Então a gente tem até alguns
estudos que falam sobre dependência e
toxicidade e o óleo nem se compara eh a
toxicidade e dependência dos
medicamentos controlados muitas vezes
utilizados aí acho que 60 70% dos
pacientes que a gente atende utilizando
ansiolítico antidepressivo né não não se
compara o grau de dependência e
toxicidade claro que existe toda uma
questão eh metabólica individual de cada
um genética né Nem todo mundo metaboliza
eh os medicamentos da mesma forma já
existem exames genéticos que nos
possibilitam ver a questão de absorção
por exemplo do thc de riscos de
dependência né maiores ou menores quanto
ao uso dos fitocanabinoides e isso
norteia bastante a gente em relação a
isso mas com certeza não se compara o
uso dos medicamentos que a gente vê aí
sendo usado indiscriminadamente né
Com certeza Concordo totalmente contigo
aí bem a gente tem algumas perguntas
aqui eu acho que é um bom momento pra
gente
respondê-las e a gente pode depois
continuar com a exposição que que você
acha pode ser eu não consigo ver as
perguntas daqui né não não eh
infelizmente esse sistema não permite
mas eu vou mostrar para você na tela
agora tá ótimo primeiramente eu queria
agradecer ao Marcelo aí por ter se
tornado um membro do canal obrigado
Marcelo um grande abraço para você nós
nos vemos aí nas lives fechadas primeira
pergunta aqui é do Eliseu essa aqui é
uma figurinha carimbada viu eu posso até
brincar com ele porque eu tenho
Liberdade com ele porque ele é um
perguntador assim esse cara pergunta
bastante nas lives viu dá D col Aí sim
vamos lá
eh uma das grandes indicações realmente
dos fitocanabinoides é pela questão de
atleta ou praticantes de atividade
física
inclusive teve até em São Paulo acho que
há dois anos atrás Um tipo um Reality
Show onde eles colocaram vários atletas
em uso dos fitocanabinoides e eles eh
dando depoimento sobre a resposta dos
fitocanabinoides em relação a isso
porque ele acaba atuando em toda a
questão de inflamação de dor de
recuperação muscular melhora da
ansiedade por exemplo desses atletas da
qualidade do sono né então os
fitocanabinoides que são utilizados é a
gente tem quando a gente fala no óleo de
cannabis a gente fala de um óleo brod
Spectrum o que que seria um óleo brod
Spectrum é um óleo isento de thc né eles
isolam totalmente o thc e ele contém
somente cbd o cbd é o maior potencial e
antiinflamatório que atua mais na
questão de inflamação e o thc mais na
questão de neuromodulação de receptores
mas de regulação de neurotransmissores
né de serotonina dopamina então no caso
do Atleta pensando nisso a gente usa um
óleo full Spectrum né que os
fitocanabinoides mais usados é o cbd com
thc que inclusive é o óleo que a gente
mais utiliza na prática na maior parte
das doenças mas a gente tem hoje
inúmeros fitocanabinoides né porque
muita gente só fala do cbd e do thc mas
a gente tem o CBN que a gente usa mais
pro sono o CBG que eu uso muito para
doenças autoimunes que ele tem um
potencial grande anti infamatório
acho que depois eu vou falando dos
outros vai lá nas perguntas é você não
você não estranha não que Eliseu já fiz
um fez umas 20 perguntas aqui viu mas
essa pergunta foi boa dele vamos paraa
próxima
aí fobia de altura sim não só fobia
fobias em gerais né crises de pânico eh
fobia de falar em público Inclusive a
gente tem eu tenho uma paciente que não
conseguia viajar de avião e nem andar de
elevador e ela tá usando há uns se meses
o marido dela é até ortopedista eu
encontrei com ele essa semana ele falou
meu Deus a minha mulher vai agora ela só
quer andar Ela vai para todos os lugares
ela não teve mais esse produto pra fobia
Qual que você indica Qual dos das
variantes o full Spectrum também o cbd
phc spum tá
legal essa não sabia porque a minha
esposa ficou mais de 10 anos sem entrar
em avião endeu ela já superou mas se eu
tivesse utilizado acho que ia ser bem
mais rápido Inclusive tem até por
exemplo de fobia de falar em público tem
um estudo eh na aqui no Brasil na
universidade de Ribeirão Preto que eles
fizeram um estudo com pessoas que tinham
fobia em falar em público e eles
utilizaram um óleo full Spectrum nessas
pessoas eh uma hora antes e submeteram
todos eles a falar em público para uma
câmera e mostraram que o efeito eh
imediato em uma hora o efeito dos que
utilizaram o óleo se sentiram muito
melhor ao falar em público será que é
por isso que tem tanto podcaster aí que
gosta de fumar um aí não não
sei mas a gente tá falando de
medicamentoso pessoal Não é não é de não
é de recreativo certo
ã deixa eu ver aqui aqui ó aqui tá
perguntando você já falou um pouquinho
sobre isso mas é um bom momento para
complementar Mou de
no então é é o que a gente tava até
falando agora um pouquinho antes eh H há
pouco mais de um ano a gente tem no
Brasil um fitocanabinoides
é semelhante ao thc digamos assim mas
ele não tem potencial de psicoatividade
e tem um mecanismo de ação completamente
diferente então o thc ele é um agonista
do receptor cb1 um o thcv ele é um
antagonista então ao mesmo tempo que o
thc pode aumentar o apetite o thcv reduz
o apetite inclusive ele é muito
comparado eh a um medicamento que a
gente teve H alguns anos atrás no Brasil
no mundo que foi proibido que é o rimon
banto não sei se tu lembra dele lembro
nunca eu mas eu lembro então rimonabant
foi um medicamento introduzido no Brasil
para emagrecimento porque ele reduzia
muito o apetite as pessoas realmente
perdiam muito peso mas ele atuava no
receptor cb1 de forma a bloquear esse
receptor totalmente er ele era um
bloqueador total do receptor cb1 Então
as pessoas realmente diminuíam o apetite
Mas como ele bloqueava o receptor ele
impedia essa regulação de
neurotransmissores tiveram muitos
efeitos colaterais psiquiátricos sabe
até casos de suicídio e por isso ele foi
proibido no mundo todo o thcv ele
bloqueia o receptor cb1 mas de forma
parcial então ele realmente causa essa
inibição do apetite mas sem os efeitos
psiquiátricos que o rimonabant causava
então ele né ele é um ótimo aliado pra
gente não só na redução do apetite Mas
em tudo que tem síndrome metabólica
diabetes obesidade então eu tenho
utilizado ele bastante com ótimos
resultados muito
bom faz ISO aqui participar de uma
maratona
exercícios memorização concentração
raciocínio rápido aprender inglês rápido
leitura
dinâmica meu
Deus então até essa questão de memória
concentração uma das indicações dos
fitocanabinoides é o TDH né essa falta
de concentração foco memória eu utilizo
principalmente o CBG o CBG ao aumenta
muito eh o foco e concentração Inclusive
eu utilizo ele para desmame de ir
ritalina de venvance porque ele faz um
efeito bem
semelhante existe em cápsula comprimido
expositório creme possui o mesmo
efeito Tá sim existe a gente tem o óleo
de cannabis né o óleo em si as gotas
existem cápsul
existe supositório existe creme eh são
várias as formas eh até o inalado então
algumas pessoas usam até o vaporizado
principalmente para quem é dependente
quem quer sair de uma dependência né de
uma um outro tipo de droga quanto ao
efeito eh o que que eu vejo como
principal problema por exemplo da
cápsula a cápsula ela tem uma dosagem eh
padrão né eu tenho ali determinado
número de gotas e para eu introduzir
começar o uso do paciente com a cápsula
eu já não gosto porque como eu falei eu
começo uma dose baixa e eu vou
manuseando isso a cápsula não me permite
esse manuseio a cápsula poderia ser
usada por exemplo quando o paciente já
tá numa dose padrão já Tá adaptado a
gente trocar isso pra cápsula mas os
cremes são muito utilizados eh
principalmente para dores para doenças
dermatológicas a gente usa bastante o
creme full Spectrum psoríase por exemplo
supositório é algo que chegou recente no
Brasil a gente já tem a possibilidade de
utilizar até lubrificante vaginal já
usei para algumas pacientes eh na
menopausa que ajuda bastante agora
quanto a comercialização
eh acho que a gente pode falar um
pouquinho como que a gente prescreve né
como que a gente as possibilidades de
prescrição e de aquisição dos pacientes
então assim hoje a gente tem algumas
formas de adquirir o óleo uma delas eh a
que eu mais utilizo é o importado Então
vou explicar um pouquinho porquê eh a
gente tem algumas eh associações no
Brasil que produzem o óleo de cannabis
com ordem judicial que produzem e vendem
Esse óleo o único porém que eu ainda
tenho resistência a prescrever os óleos
das associações é que a gente não tem no
Brasil laboratório que Lauda
Tecnicamente esses olhos e que me diga a
proporção exata e os fitocanabinoides
que contém ali então muitas vezes no
início que a gente se prescrevia muito a
importação ainda era muito difícil Às
vezes o paciente Tava tendo um ótimo
resultado e numa segunda terceira compra
o resultado não era o mesmo então eu não
sei exatamente o que tem ali hoje a
gente tem nas farmácias para compra eh
imediata alguns fitocanabinoides eh que
são liberados pela Anvisa eles são
importados e vendidos aqui no Brasil e
esses precisam de receita controlada
receituário Azul alguns amarelo para que
a gente adquira mas esses Óleos da
farmácia a gente só tem óleo full
Spectrum com cbd e thc e óleos broad
Spectrum com somente cbd eu não tenho a
possibilidade dos outros
fitocanabinoides como CBN para insônia
como esse thcv que eu falei que eu tenho
utilizado bastante a gente não tem esses
fitocanabinoides ainda na farmácia então
o que eu mais utilizo hoje são os óleos
importados que há 5 anos atrás era muito
mais difícil então a Anvisa levava às
vezes 3S meses para liberar um processo
de importação e demorava muito ao início
do tratamento hoje isso é muito mais
rápido né então hoje quando a gente
atende o paciente e envia a receita
paraa Anvisa a autorização da Anvisa é
quase imediata não leva nem 12 horas e a
partir do momento que está liberado pela
Anvisa o o óleo chega até a casa do
paciente em 7 a 10 dias então o
tratamento realmente inicia-se muito
rápido Maravilha tem uma pergunta aqui
do
Eliseu tô com um probleminha aqui na no
microfone que ele quer saber tudo ao
mesmo tempo aqui
ó a diferença dos fitocanabinoides
eu acho que você tá estudando o assunto
hein
é vamos lá então como eu falei antes a
gente só falava do cbd e do thc hoje a
gente fala de muitos outros
fitocanabinoides e talvez inúmeros
outros que a gente ainda vai descobrir
porque ao longo desses se anos aí eu vi
muita coisa né sendo descoberta o th o
cbd vamos eh tentar separar um pouquinho
o cbd ele tem mais um potencial
antiinflamatório ele atua Principalmente
nos nos receptores cb2 em órgãos
periféricos
então quando eu vou atuar paraa
ansiedade com efeito antiinflamatório eu
sempre associo o cbd já o thc ele é o
ativo né de psicoatividade mas ele atua
mais em receptores cerebrais então tudo
que eu quero atuar para
neurotransmissores na insônia eh Na
ansiedade depressão Eu sempre associo
tenho aquele pouquinho né que eu falei
do 0.3% do thc o CBG é é ótimo
antiinflamatório então Muitas vezes os
fitocanabinoides Eles não estão isolados
eles vê juntos em muitos dos olhos por
isso a importância do laudo técnico para
eu saber qual fitocanabinoides
tem naquele óleo mas o CBG eu uso
principalmente nas doenças autoimunes eh
no TDH Como Eu mencionei o CBN é muito
utilizado para insônia então a gente usa
muito ele para distúrbios do sono o CBC
também para doenças inflamatórias para
analgesia eu gosto bastante do Delta 8 o
Delta 8 ele é um Delta 8 thc né então
ele vem pro Brasil eh um Delta 8 puro é
um thc puro A diferença é que ele não
tem o potencial psicoativo do thc né Ele
é um thc diferente que é o chamado Delta
8 eu uso ele para insônia também mas
tenho usado mais o CBN e a vantagem para
mim do Delta 8 muitas vezes é num caso
de dor crônica por exemplo ou no caso
que eu quero aumentar o o thc do
paciente mas como eu tenho a
possibilidade desses óleos só com até
0.3% às vezes eu introduzo para uma
fibromialgia para um quadro de dor para
um tratamento de câncer um óleo full
Spectrum com cbd e thc associado ao
delta o pensando no aumento da proporção
de thc que eu quero para esse paciente e
o thcv eu já mencionei mais paraa
síndrome metabólica redução do
apetite Acho que mais ou menos isso E
lembrando que muitas vezes eles vêm
Associados né então o thcv ele é junto
com o cbd então o óleo que eu utilizo de
thcv ele tem metade da proporção ele é
um para um de cbd com thcv então eu atuo
tanto na ansiedade quanto na síndrome
metabólica o CBG por exemplo Geralmente
os óleos CBG São óleos full Spectrum
então ele tem cbd thc e CBG a mesma
coisa o CBN ele tem cbd thc e CBN e
muitas vezes eu posso associar mais de
um tipo de óleo né então eu tenho um
paciente com uma doença autoimune mas
que também tem insônia eu posso usar um
um full Spectrum com CBG pela manhã e
posso usar um full Spectrum com CBN à
noite então nem sempre eu utilizo um
único óleo pro paciente muitas vezes eu
associo dois ou até três
fitocanabinoides diferentes
muito
interessante você comentou aí sobre
fologia eu vou pegar um fone de ouvido
porque acho tá dando o microfoninho
Enquanto isso você explica
aí Responde essa pergunta por favor tá
fibromialgia É sim uma das grandes
indicações né É uma doença que a gente
tem como uma doença
autoimune mas que a gente vê a O
componente ansioso depressivo a maior
parte das pacientes principalmente
mulheres com diagnóstico de fibromialgia
tem um quadro de depressão muito grande
associada né e o óleo atua em toda essa
fisiopatologia da doença melhorando não
só a dor pelo potencial antiinflamatório
e analgésico mas melhorando o composto
né de ansiedade a qualidade do Sono a
gente tem vários estudos de uso para
fibromialgia inclusive um brasileiro eh
que foi feito em Florianópolis onde eles
usaram óleo full Spectrum para mulheres
e acompanharam essas mulheres ao longo
de algumas semanas aumentando a dose
gradativamente semanalmente e mostrando
o efeito delas em relação a todos esses
fatores e melhorou não só como eu falei
a analgesia mas melhorou a qualidade de
vida melhorou a qualidade do sono né
então a dor realmente melhora muito
rápido quando a gente introduz o óleo
pra fibromialgia questão de duas semanas
assim de uso a paciente já sente uma
grande diferença
tem
mais tá me
ouvindo
Oi eu tô é porque dando microfonia T
ligando aqui você tem um fone de ouvido
não tô sem
é porque tá
eu vou te colocar mais uma pergunta para
você responder e eu vou tentar resolver
essa questão aqui tá
tá é útil para seis
tipos pros seis tipos de causas de
Alzheimer então assim como eu a gente
usa para todas as doenças
neurodegenerativas né e no Alzheimer em
si ele atua em toda a fisiopatologia da
doença em relação à placa Bet amiloide a
redução de neuroinflamação ao aumento do
apetite que muitas vezes esses pacientes
eh necessitam então eu sempre associo o
óleo na doença de alzheimer e muitas
vezes até de forma preventiva num início
de Diagnóstico eu acho que quanto antes
a gente introduzir o óleo nesses
pacientes melhor para não progressão ali
do
sintomas Maravilha você tá me ouvindo Tô
beleza tava aquela interferência agora
isso os focis tem algo a ver com
testosterona ajuda a baixar aumentar a
testosterona na testosterona em si eu
nunca vi estudos em relação a isso uma
coisa que a gente vê bastante é em
relação à Saúde da Mulher em si né
Principalmente na mulher pós pausa
Porque na questão hormonal O que que a
gente tem enzimas no nosso corpo que são
responsáveis por sintetizar e degradar
os endocanabinoides que a gente produz
né e o estrogênio especificamente um
hormônio que o homem tem mas que a gente
sabe que a mulher tem 10 vezes mais o
estrogênio Ele regula a atividade da
anandamida que é um endocanabinoide que
o nosso corpo produz porque o o
estrogênio ele inibe a enzima deixa eu
ver se fica claro ele inibe a enzima que
degrada a anandamida então na menopausa
com a diminuição do estrogênio eu
aumento a enzima que degrada então toda
a mulher menopausada que tem diminuição
do estrogênio ela vai ter diminuição de
endocanabinoides e esse é um dos motivos
pelos quais a gente acredita dos
sintomas da pós-menopausa né que vai
influenciar no fogacho na redução da
libido na diminuição da ição Então acho
que vale muito a pena eu tenho algumas
pacientes que eram super resistentes ao
fogacho mesmo com modulação hormonal
bioidêntica e que a gente teve ótimos
ótimo resultado assim com o uso do Óleo
mas da testosterona em si eu nunca vi
estudo sobre isso também não também não
precisa dar uma olhada mas surgiu essa
pergunta aqui por isso que eu
tô trazendo para você você tá ouvindo
algum ruído algum zumbido
tá então é só com meu pone aqui porque
eu tava tendo antes uns problemas de
interferência mas eu acho que eu
consegui isolar isso daí mas uma
perguntinha
aí pés
dormentes
assim não consigo ver o uso de um óleo
isolado só para dormência nos pés tem
que Identificar qual que é a causa
efetivamente disso
né Tu consegue ver alguma
coisa Não realmente concordo com você
tem que fazer um
diagnóstico exato do que tá acontecendo
e não sair tratando só pelo sintomas né
assim eu já usei pernas inquietas aquela
pessoa que não consegue ficar com as
pernas paradas um uso muito grande que
eu tive pós-covid eu tive alguns
pacientes pós-covid com tremor essencial
e realmente tem uma grande melhora com o
óleo mas para pés dormentes isoladamente
não sei te falar É mas tá certo concordo
plenamente com o que você
disse uma perguntinha aqui já fez 335
perguntas Então a gente tem inúmeros
receptores né a gente falava muito do o
que mais a gente fala né o cb1 e o cb2 o
receptor cb1 ele tá Expresso
principalmente na parte do sistema
nervoso central e o receptor cb2
principalmente em órgãos periféricos né
mas a gente tem o receptor o trpv1 a
gente tem inúmeros outros receptores que
os fitocanabinoides também
atuam aqui uma pergunta de uma
profissional de saúde uma dentista
sim eh hoje o a prescrição do Óleo de
cannabis é liberada eh para médicos e
dentistas né veterinários utilizam
bastante mas ainda não podem fazer o
processo de importação e eu tenho um
curso online que a gente fez algumas
algumas vezes presencial agora tá só no
online que para médicos e dentistas e
tem muita aplicabilidade na odontologia
realmente quer me falar o o link eu
coloco aqui na tela pessoal eh w link
fácil ou é alguma coisa é fácil é
cancare C A NN
né de inglês
C com.br tá mostrar na tela pessoal eu
vou deixar
inclusive
rando
aqui pronto vou deixar rando na tela
também inclusive no curso tem uma aula
específica de uma dentista que fez PS
Lair com a gente a k e ela tem utilizado
bastante para bruxismo para várias
indicações cefaleia e até em questão de
pré-operatório pré-procedimento
porque a gente usa tanto na odontologia
na medicina também a questão do uso do
cannabis no pré e no pós-operatório
paraa melhora da inflamação da
recuperação diminuição do uso dos
medicamentos né opioides
antiinflamatórios analgésicos com o uso
do
Óleo
maravilha então esse escrevi certo aí o
n o nome do site né sim Maravilha Deixa
eu tô tentando configurar aqui para ele
ficar rodando
em como um B mas eu esqueci como é que
faz isso depois eu mostro de
novo bem vou continuar aqui nas
perguntas
ah essa pergunta do Raimundo é
boa então tem muita aplicabilidade no
autismo né eu tenho muitos pacientes que
usam o que que o eu vejo na prática tá
eh principalmente melhora da questão
social de né do convívio social melhora
da questão alimentar geralmente esses
pacientes têm muita seletividade
alimentar eh melhora da qualidade do
Sono claro que junto com toda uma dieta
e suplementação né que a gente faz em
conjunto para para esses pacientes mas
ajuda muito na melhora desses sintomas
sim e no início até as mães tinham muito
meso medo do uso do thc pensando nas
crianças mas hoje a gente sabe que a
gente utiliza óleos full Spectrum com
proporção pequena de thc e melhores
efeitos nas crianças com
autismo aqui ó jabazinho para
você Sim atendo bastante
online como é que o pessoal faz para
marcar com você
online tenho que te passar um contato
você quer me passar um telefone eu posso
pôr na tela também é
47 perí
8854 Hum
ok Dea eu ver
se eu fiz certo tá certo
isto Então quem quiser passar com D
Carol aí aí o número de contato para
agendamento eu vou deixar também ISO
aqui deixa eu ver se cons
dear pera aí deixa eu faz um negócio
aqui pronto agora descobri como é que
faz para deixar
rolando na tela aqui pronto tá rolando
na tela aí
Eh vamos lá pra próxima
pergunta
uso medicamento para Pânico crônico e
depressão crônica eu posso usar esse
medicamento e como conseguir então como
conseguir eh Eu mencionei as formas que
a gente tem de prescrição a primeira
coisa é realmente uma consulta médica
porque seja pela farmácia com receita
controlada ou pela Anvisa a gente tem
que fazer o processo de liberação né
Então a primeira coisa realmente é uma
consulta médica quando a gente introduz
o o óleo eh a gente introduz junto com
os medicamentos de uso crônico porque a
gente não é simplesmente começar o óleo
e largar todos os medicamentos então por
isso que eu falo que no início é um
acompanhamento realmente próximo quando
o óleo chega o paciente tem que me
avisar e a partir de então no início ele
vai me dar notícias todas toda semana né
então a gente introduz o óleo junto com
os medicamentos aos poucos a gente vai
Possivelmente aumentando a a dosagem do
óleo e fazendo o desmame lento e gradual
dos remédios então realmente é um
processo né é uma coisa que não existe
um padrão isso é importante a gente
falar não existe padrão de dose eh Por
comorbidade que é algo que eu espero que
não exista nunca porque como a gente tem
um sistema endocanabinoide único
individual cada um tem um corpo um nível
de inflamação né não tem como ter uma
dose padrão como tem com os medicamentos
né tal gramagem de tanto em tanto tempo
realmente é muito individual então var
muito a questão do desmame dos
medicamentos né pode pode ser que em
dois meses a gente tire os remédios Pode
ser que isso leve seis meses então é
muito variável mas é muito
possível você já falou um pouquinho
sobre isso mas se você puder
complementar
aqui por conta da na Lúcia ter tido a
gentileza de deixar o super
Sticker então na demência qualquer
quadro de demência seja por doença
neurodegenerativa né Alzheimer Parkinson
como a gente falou como demência senil
eh Tem sim grande aplicabilidade pela
questão cerebral pela questão de
neuroinflamação né a gente reduz muito a
neuroinflamação então a gente pode usar
não só de forma preventiva Mas curativa
claro que a gente não vai impedir uma
demência de acontecer mas a gente pode
impedir a evolução né retardar aí a
evolução e progressão do
quadro e Existe alguma interação dos
olhos com
suplementos não com alguns medicamentos
sim tem alguns medicamentos eh que a
gente vê esse tipo de interação por isso
a gente tem que passar pelo médico
realmente fazer esse desmame acompanhado
com suplementos não eh mas o contrário
sim existem suplementos que auxiliam a
gente eh no controle e na melhora do
sistema endocanabinoide por exemplo todo
o paciente meu em uso do óleo vai usar
ômega-3 é um suplemento obrigatório já
que eu entendo que os endocanabinoides
são produzidos pelos ácidos graxos então
a melhora eh o uso do ômega-3 sempre
elic carnitina é um suplemento que eu
uso bastante pela questão do Ômega né
dos ácidos grassos de cadeia longa só
conseguirem entrar na mitocôndria com a
L Carnitina eh outro suplemento que tem
muita aplicabilidade que eu uso muito se
chama PE P
Active porque o pé ele tem um efeito
semelhante a anandamida que é um
endocanabinoide então quando eu
introduzo o pé pro paciente eu acabo
melhorando a função da anandamida
aumentando a anandamida no sistema então
tem alguns suplementos que me auxiliam
na melhora até do efeito do Óleo mas não
como
interação interessante você já fiz
alguma associação
de copaíba com carabin então Eh até
algumas pessoas que trabalham com óleo
essencial Eu já vi até falarem Ah mas o
óleo de copaíba se assemelha ao ao óleo
de cannabis ou vou substituir o óleo de
cannabis pelo óleo de copaíba o que que
acontece o óleo de copaíba eh ele é rico
em Beta cariofileno então o óleo de
copaíba e feito de betac cariofileno tá
e o óleo de cannabis então quando eu
extraio da planta o os fitocanabinoides
e eu tenho aquele laudo técnico que Eu
mencionei eu não tenho somente eh os
fitocanabinoides eu tenho uma coisa
chamada de terpenos né terpenos é algo
que contém na planta os óleos essenciais
são feitos de terpenos né Então existe
um terpeno que é o Bet cariofileno que
tem alto potencial
ório que muitas vezes quando eu vou
escolher o tipo de óleo Eu por exemplo
para doença autoimune eu escolho um óleo
que tem cbd thc mas que tenha um certo
nível de Beta cariofileno e o óleo de
copaíba ele é o betac cariofileno né
então ele atua no receptor cb2 tem um
potencial antiinflamatório eu uso ele
associado eh com os fitocanabinoides mas
não tem como comparar o efeito claro que
o efeito do cbd é muit muito muito maior
e uma coisa que a gente pode manipular o
betac cariofileno então na farmácia de
manipulação ele tem o nome de refil eu
uso também para todo o paciente com
doença autoimune o refil associado na
suplementação porque eu tô dando um
betac cariofileno a mais pro paciente
para atuar em conjunto com aquele
receptor cb2 então a copaíba é como se
fosse o refil que é esse betac
cariofileno que também tem na planta ISO
só que o refil mais potente do que o
cariofileno natural do copaíba é que eu
posso utilizar doses mais altas né como
eu manipulo eu posso utilizar doses mais
altas mas nada passando mais concentrado
né mais concentrado mas nada IMP utilize
o óleo associado ao a
copaíba
perfeito
H vamos
lá o gilan sendo carinhoso aí obrigado
pelos seus comentários gilan gilan é um
um seguidor antigo do
canal existe aplicação de
fitocanabinoides para
candidiase para candidiase a gente já a
gente tem óvulos né
de de cannabis já eh que podem ser usado
para candidíase mas a gente tem que
entender que candidas de repetição é uma
questão muitas vezes intestinal né sim é
o que a gente faz se a gente corrige o
intestino corrige o organismo a gente
muitas vezes Corrige a candidíase então
acaba que como a gente corrige isso né
na suplementação e no estilo de vida do
paciente dificilmente eu uso óvulo
perfeito ah fala um pouquinho de fitab
enchaqueca
analgésico né então para enxaqueca a
gente usa sempre um óleo full Spectrum
com cbd e thc e tem sim grandes
resultados PR
enxaqueca
maravilha você já comentou aqui do
doenças autoimunes né que você tá
utilizando né atuar nesses casos aí Quer
comentar mais alguma coisa a respeito
é doença autoimune Independente de qual
seja é uma doença inflamatória né então
o cbd vai ter um grande potencial ali
anti-inflamatório porque o óleo atua
realmente em toda a fisiopatologia do
desenvolvimento da doença autoimune né
tanto aquela regulação que a gente sabe
da fisiopatologia entre treg e th17
então ele melhora muito a inflamação na
psor exema como eu falei a gente pode
utilizar o creme de full Spectrum com
cbd e thc e associar até o óleo junto ao
creme eu uso bastante para psoríase e
regride mesmo regride muito claro que
assim a gente fala muito da integrativa
né a gente não usa nada isolado então
toda doença autoimune que é o que eu
mais atuo hoje é é é doença
autoimune então a gente faz toda uma
dieta exclusão de alimentos em
inflamatórios suplementação aumento de
vitamina D então é um conjunto né de
fatores a gente nunca entra com óleo
isolado você usa ldn junto com
canabinoides sempre
uso bacana você não vê nenhum problema
dessa sessão né não maravilha Tem alguma
indicação para par sexual de
fitocanabinoides Não
entendi essa pergunta aqui ó
intimidade sexual então alguns estudos
mostram melhora a da libido mas esses
estudos são principalmente em mulheres
como Eu mencionei Como tem muita
repercussão na menopausa pela
deficiência do estradiol as mulheres
relatam melhora da libido mas eu nunca
vi estudo em homens relatando melhora de
libido com
oso
disociativo desrealização
É acho que isso que ela
colocou tros psiquiátricos aí de
personalidade vamos vamos deixar mais
abrangente isso aí eh assim a gente
utiliza o óleo para várias doenças
psiquiátricas desde esquizofrenia
bipolaridade toque eh tem indicação para
esquizofrenia sim uma coisa que vale a
pena ressaltar né eu falei bastante da
associação do cbd e do thc 90% das
idades a indicação vai ser de um óleo
que contenha thc associado a única a os
únicos casos né onde a gente utiliza eu
principalmente os únicos casos onde eu
utilizo um óleo broad Spectrum isento
total de thc São nas doenças
psiquiátricas com riscos de surtos então
a esquizofrenia bipolaridade toque
doenças que TM riscos de surto o thc
pode predispor esses surtos né então a
gente usa um óleo sem thc nessas
comobidades
mas tem grande melhor a bipolaridade
então eu uso bastante esquizofrenia não
muito porque a psiquiatria em si não é a
minha prática né mas bipolaridade eu
tenho vários pacientes que usam e
relatam bastante
melhora aqui é uma pergunta
interessante curativo ou paliativo ambos
né preventivo curativo e
paliativo então a gente pode usar como
forma preventiva muitas vezes curativo
desmame de medicamentos e muitas vezes
paliativo né tratamento de câncer por
exemplo eh dor eh mostra muita melhora
nos sintomas do do tratamento do Câncer
em quimioterapia radioterapia melhora
dos sintomas frente ao tratamento então
usado das duas
formas
beleza
e
como é que você enxerga o futuro da
Medicina cannabinoid nos próximos anos e
as regulações no
Brasil para que para que lado você acha
que essas coisas estão andando assim eu
vi uma evolução muito grande nos últimos
cinco anos frente a isso porque o óleo
foi liberado no Brasil em 2015 é muito
recente né E como eu falei antes eu
levava 5 meses para iniciar um
tratamento que hoje eu levo 10 dias e em
2021 o Brasil aprovou um projeto de lei
sobre a questão da da produção e
comercialização do óleo aqui no Brasil
claro que ainda falta essa questão do
laboratório para laudar Tecnicamente
esses olhos mas eu acredito que seja uma
coisa próxima e realmente eu acho que tá
evoluindo muito é uma coisa que veio
para ficar né não se não tem como se
discutir mais algo que eu ouvi muito lá
no início Ah eu sou contra ou eu sou a
favor do Óleo isso não se discute mais
né o sistema endocanabinoide tá aí tá no
corpo humano vai ter que entrar na grade
curricular acadêmica os alunos e médicos
vão ter que estudar a respeito né e eu
falo que hoje a acho que 1% dos médicos
brasileiros prescrevem o cannabis a
cannabis ainda porque é algo que a gente
teve que estudar depois né a gente tá
tendo que estudar agora mas eu tive
muita questão no início da prescrição de
colegas médicos falarem Ah mas eu não
quero que você use eu não sou a favor e
o paciente hoje eu falo que muitas vezes
ele lê e ele entende da própria doença
mais do que muitos profissionais porque
ele só estuda o que ele tem então ele
sabe eu tenho pacientes que me mandam o
último artigo e novidade que aconteceu
na Alemanha porque ele tá ali estudando
e ele quer o que tem de melhor para pra
doença dele e nesses anos todos
prescrevendo e explicando isso pros
pacientes eu nunca tive um paciente que
se negasse a usar tipo eu sou contra né
eu falo que o preconceito maior que a
gente tem é muito mais dos profissionais
do que dos próprios pacientes Então hoje
a gente tem como importar todos esses
tipos de óleo e até a questão de algumas
prefeituras né que muitas pessoas não
sabem e que eu acho que vale a pena a
gente difundir disseminar isso que a
gente consegue por ordem judicial
entrando com o processo eu tenho vários
pacientes que conseguiram o custeio de
todo o tratamento pelo plano de saúde né
quando a gente indica a prescrição
entrando judicialmente muitos conseguem
pelo plano e muitos conseguem pelo SUS
vários pacientes com autismo eh que
entram judicialmente com advogado
conseguem todo o tratamento pelo SUS e
já tem várias prefeituras eh no Brasil
que já autorizaram pelo SUS a prescrição
do médico então hoje várias prefeituras
o médico pode prescrever e e a
Prefeitura vai custear o tratamento
alguns a gente tem que entrar
judicialmente hoje a maioria
judicialmente Mas é uma questão de tempo
que realmente a evolução vai acontecer
né e eu vejo muita evolução em relação a
isso muito bom o pro autismo Qual que é
o produto que você acha melhor o full
Spectrum o full mesmo tá OK pergunta
interessante aqui da Regina também
indicar tem fã reagente mas sem uma
doença autoimune ativa com certeza né
muitas vezes a gente vê o fã reagente ou
até o fator reumatoide eh o fator
reumatoide a gente sabe que altera às
vezes 5 10 Anos Antes de uma doença
autoimune efetivamente ser diagnosticada
o fã a mesma coisa mas já mostra que tem
uma alteração ali no sistema imunológico
que tem uma predisposição ao
desenvolvimento de uma doença autoimune
então o óleo poderia ser usado sim como
forma preventiva de modular esse sistema
imunológico de atuar como forma
anti-inflamatória para prevenir esse
desenvolvimento eu não vejo o cbd de
forma alguma como potencial de causar
irritabilidade eu não sei qual que é o
óleo que você usa éo ele contém thc ou
ele é isento de
thc vamos esperar ele responder até ele
responder vamos ver se tem mais alguma
útima estamos aqui indo pro final da
nossa Live viu pessoal vou vou poder
mais uns 10 minutos pra gente poder
liberar a Caroline né paraa sua família
paraas suas atividades
hã deixa eu ver se tem mais alguma
pergunta boa
aqui
ah interess aqui é uma boa
pergunta epilepsia a maioria das vezes
um óleo foi o Spectrum também então como
eu falei hoje Eu só uso o broad Spectrum
basicamente para aquelas condições
psiquiátricas com risco de surtos na nas
outras todas as outras comorbidades eu
uso um full Spectrum associando ou não
aqueles outros fitocanabinoides
Maravilha serviria para Hashimoto
sim uma doença autoimune inflamatória
assim como o Hashimoto das doenças
autoimunes é a mais tranquila digamos
assim de tratamento e controle e
remissão eu já usei algumas vezes para
hasimoto mas só naqueles casos eh de
anticorpos realmente resistentes a
redução Com tudo o que a gente faz de
Conduta Mas primeiro o paciente fazendo
tudo que a gente orienta né em relação
porque doença autoimune é muito
complicado né hoje até eu atendi uma
paciente com 17 anos com espondilite
anquilosante teve o diagnóstico aos 15
anos de idade e quando eu fui conversar
com ela assim um intestino péssimo vai
ao banheiro duas vezes por semana quando
vai hidratação nenhuma uma alimentação
extremamente inflamatória então quando
eu pego esse tipo de paciente eu não vou
prescrever o óleo de imediato porque eu
não vou prescrever o óleo como se fosse
a solução dos seus problemas se você não
quer fazer o mínimo necessário para que
a gente tenha sucesso em relação a isso
né então o rimoto se o paciente for
fazer toda a dieta que a gente orienta
retirar os alimentos
inflamatórios na maioria das vezes a
gente tem sucesso Na remissão só com
essas condutas
né bem O Eliseu ele quer estudar
exaustivamente até desmaiar sobre
canabinoides que que você recomenda para
ele de livro que livro livro que ele
pode ler até desmaiar
aí nossa sobre todos os f canabinoides
tem e o Tratado de de cannabis medicinal
que é um Tratado de dois volumes bem
grande mas que tem bastante
informação até tem um livro meu marido
escreveu um livro sobre o uso dos
fitocanabinoides para atletas mas é mais
específicos para esporte né Para quem
pratica atividade física que é um livro
mais tranquilo de leitura Mas tem
bastante material tem muita coisa como é
que eu não desse tratado por Elise eu
comprar aí nossa deix eu acho TR vai
comprar acho ele tá falando isso aí mas
não vai comprar eu quero ver hein você
lê tudo sobre o assunto
é eu vou pegar aqui para eu te
falar acho que eu não mostrar né mas é o
é chama tratado mesmo Tratado de
cannabis medicinal Tratado de cannabis
medicinal é bem simples o nome né Tem um
um autor principal aí é da Ana deixa eu
ver o sobrenome
dela achar
aqui Ana Gabriela r Ah é nacional esse
livro é nacional ah Ana Gabriela Ron
pronto viu eliz vai estudar até
exaustivamente o livro Aí tá certo vamos
para vamos pra última pergunta para
poder liberar você
ah deixa eu escolher uma pergunta boa
aqui ah vamos encerrar com isso aqui o
para você falar umas palavrinhas pra
Lúcia orientá-la minha M escreve não
acredito Pois é exatamente isso Lúcia eu
tive muito problema com isso eh
principalmente alguns anos atrás porque
os pacientes chegavam Querendo entender
querendo usar e é o que eu falo hoje o
paciente não aceita mais a resposta do
Ah você não deve usar Ah eu eu acho que
não serve para você não serve Por quê eu
não devo usar por quê né então hoje eu
falo que o profissional médico ele tem
que entender que esse sistema existe que
a aplicabilidade é muito grande e se ele
não quer estudar sobre o assunto para
ele prescrever ele tem que ser humilde
de falar eu não entendo mas vamos
procurar alguém que entenda ou indicar
alguém que realmente faça isso em
conjunto né e é o que a gente vê porque
muitas vezes os pacientes acabam o
primeiro paciente que Eu tratei para
Parkinson ele tá usando óleo há uns 6
anos e o neurologista dele fez
exatamente a mesma coisa tá falou não
quero que você use não é indicado para
você e quando ele chegou aqui a gente
começou a usar que a gente começou a
desmamar os medicamentos Hoje ele
reduziu Total A levodopa tá ele tá muito
bem eu vejo ele hoje 6 anos depois
talvez da mesma forma que eu ouvi há 6
anos atrás O que é muito difícil
Parkinson né Realmente postergar toda
essa evolução o que aconteceu foi que
ele não voltou mais ao neurologista e a
gente como médico não quer isso né eu
sempre quis acompanhar em conjunto com
outros profissionais que a gente pudesse
ter essa conversa em relação ao
tratamento principalmente na hora do
desmame dos medicamentos fazer isso em
conjunto então não tem como ser
resistente a isso né
Eh preciso dar um recadinho para na
Lúcia eu acho que ela não prestou
atenção você falou vários momentos da
Live sobre demência ela mandou um super
chat você respondeu eu coloquei o super
chat dela na tela você respondeu e ela
tá mandando mensagem de novo serveria
para demência serveria para demência
serve na Lúcia volta ao vídeo quando não
tiver na forma gravada assiste
direitinho com calma que você vai ver
todos os momentos dessa Live que a dout
Caroline falou do uso dos
fitocanabinoides para demência Tá bom
você deve ter perdido o momento que ela
falou nós respondemos sua pergunta e
você deve ter perdido esse momento tá
bom vamos encerrar
agora queria te agradecer aí pela sua
gentileza pela sua disponibilidade para
responder as
perguntas você foi bastante assertiva
demonstrou um domínio muito grande do
tema e realmente Esse vídeo é muito rico
aqui no canal Vamos deixar aqui pro
pessoal assistir depois e quer falar
umas palavras finais aí ah Eu que
agradeço foi um prazer prer enorme
realmente é algo que que eu gosto muito
de falar porque eu vejo um resultado
efetivo e quanto mais a gente disseminar
esse tipo de informação a gente se
ajudar em relação a isso eu falo como né
Nós profissionais nas aulas de
pós-graduação eu mantenho contato com
boa parte dos alunos e tiro dúvidas e
depois falo começa a PR escrever
qualquer coisa né me fala vamos
acompanhando isso junto Porque quando
mais a gente realmente falar do assunto
a gente desmistificar muito isso mais
pessoas com certeza a gente vai poder
ajudar então foi um enorme prazer eu te
agradeço e de repente a gente pode fazer
uma segunda Live ter umas perguntas aqui
que nós não
respondemos de repente para te falar de
TPM também aí que eu você deve ter
alguma experiência com us de TPM também
né É na saúde da mulher em geral tem
muita aplicabilidade né endometriose eu
uso bastante
muito bem então então pessoal Muito
obrigado pela Muito obrigado a você
principalmente Caroline e muito obrigado
a todos vocês que assistiram essa Live
não se esqueçam que fica sempre gravado
divulguem essa Live pro seus familiares
seus amigos nas redes sociais no
WhatsApp tem muito material aqui pessoal
que fic chateado materiais assim
riquíssimos por tá na forma de Live às
vezes por ser um vídeo longo e vocês às
vezes deixam de divulgar seus contatos
se você não quer assistir um vídeo longo
de uma vez assiste 10 minutos o YouTube
Deixa marcado na sua timeline o ponto
que você parou de assistir você pode
assistir um vídeo longo em segmentos
mais curtos tá bom não deixa aproveitar
toda a riqueza esse material Aqui nós
temos esses convidados maravilhosos
mostrando todo seu conhecimento sem
Papas na Língua eh sem restringir
informação para vocês tchau tchau
pessoal até a próxima um beijo no
coração de vocês vocês são fé
da